do you support this Camp dude it looks
scary because like the first thought I
had was yo our kids don't know if
they're a boy or a girl and their kids
are getting ready to kill Japanese
people and they already know they're
bayonets right
[Music]
so apparently there's a summer camp for
children in China where they teach the
kids how to bum and stab Japanese
soldiers whoa this is so funny
next shark posts on this because the
comments are hilarious bro let's go what
are the comments on that by the way like
what are some examples they love it
so the reviews are in they're like
serves those Japs right that's exactly
and I'm just kidding no no no no that
was top comment no no I wish um anime
yeah obviously uh there's video of this
Camp so please enjoy the sights and
sounds of this Chinese children I bet
they're pretty good at it summer camp
okay children
stab the dirty Japanese
holy [__]
this is kind of so cute
for kids
oh
bro this is how they're getting their
military right oh yeah dude
I had that as a kid is that a little
scary propaganda
what do you mean like they're not
actually doing that it was just one day
it was like an event oh and they filmed
it yeah and then now it's posting all
over Instagram yeah like when I looked
into it it was to it was like not a
theme park but it was like to give them
the experience of that but also teach
them about what happened in war so it's
a history lesson yeah that's why if you
look at the first thing they're stabbing
Japanese Imperial Army guys the old
uniforms yeah because it's like a
history lesson and things like that so
that would be the equivalent of us kids
she's but do they have that being uh
Nazis oh yeah oh it's old right so
they're not like these dirty Japanese
like today they're it's like it's like
we're killing Nazis on our video games
yeah but don't aren't they're still
Japanese guys in world yeah but I mean
it's different because it's
when we stabbed Nazis in video games
we're not thinking Germans today no so
that's basically the same concept here
okay it's Imperial Japanese Army
necessarily considered Japan as a whole
it shouldn't but idiots on the next
shark comments do believe they're like
serves them right they deserve it um you
know okay they don't know the difference
between that makes sense oh my god do
you support this Camp dude it looks
scary because like the first thought I
had was yo our kids don't know if
they're a boy or a girl and their kids
are getting ready to kill Japanese
people either way they're bayonets right
dropping mortar in the freaking dude in
the mortar tube that's pretty cool
like I would go to that camp now that
looks so fun I gotta ride in a little
mini tank I'd do that a little bit Yeah
and afterwards I was like I wish I had
that as a comparison just hurts so hard
when you said that like where the two
directions of the countries are going
yeah because that's not the first video
I've seen I've seen kids like taking
apart pistols in class like boys and
girls I've just seen all that's pretty
cool I think that's cool well you know
what American kids they're getting
um Call of Duty they're getting mod
they're like playing video games and
then they're shooting and having mad
hours clocked in for those they're
really good at watching other kids open
up toys
and they're really good iPads you know
that's pretty cool yeah they are that's
something right you think that's uh
helpful in any military capacity Jesus
man have you noticed how like a lot of
kids don't even go outside and play
anymore man they're all like into their
[__] iPad back in days we used to go
out there and I just come back to like
Darkness yeah yeah like kids don't play
with like toy guns or anything anymore
you can't oh you can't no you can but
you can't you know yeah yeah it's true a
lot of schools have like yeah no like
even water gun policy or anything
remotely close if it's a la thing
because when I go outside like in the
country like you see normal life yeah I
think it's an early thing I think it's a
city thing big city thing yeah big city
big city because you can go out to Depot
sea and you'll still see kids it's
playing yeah that's true we did uh Geo's
like a chaperone throwing a taika school
events and then one of them was like a
um it was for summer and then all these
kids had water guns and they're shooting
each other yeah and I was like oh [__]
that's great it was so refreshing to see
yeah a lot of schools just don't even
have stuff like that I know I it always
warms my heart when I see children
blasting the [__] out of each other
because it brings me back to my
childhood where I would you know do
slow-mo death moves and yeah
we were hanging out over at uh LBX do
you know LBX is no it's Long Beach it's
like right next to the airport it's an
old uh airplane Hangar that they turned
into like a food court
and um outside there's like a grass
patch area where a bunch of kids are
playing and uh my girl's never been
there before and I brought her there we
live in a complex where there's no kids
wow like the area that we never see kids
we go out there's all these kids playing
they're all different races and we're
just like is isn't that crazy that by
Instinct you want to look at that and
think it's an ad
damn because it's so culturally diverse
that it looks like it was intended yeah
but it's naturally occurring and you
can't believe it anymore those are real
life ads it's like uncanny valley in
your mind you're like nah that's a this
is some kind of Claritin ad yeah this is
a simulation for sure yeah it's that
like but then again it's like it's our
choice to live in the city then you know
we're gonna see what we see right in
terms of getting kids indoctrinated
early yeah I'm for that
I thought that was just crazy to see
because I don't know what the American
equivalent to something like that would
be stabbing Redcoats
Elmo loading up the [__] uh the
musket yeah that's true like going to
those Civil War history like oh that is
true that stuff is cool when I was a kid
yeah that's true and then you shoot like
Southerners or whatever
North or whatever get the Yankees
damn that is pretty everybody they did
that I don't know I feel like
you know the people that want to be like
super peace and stuff and they don't
want their children to do any of this
stuff uh that I get it if the world was
just America and there was no other
threats right because like you can be
peace all you want but then how you're
gonna control the the bad guys that want
to take you over yeah that's like being
um what do you call it the Puritans or
the Quakers or whatever they were hella
passive right so if people took over
their house or they didn't do anything
yeah they didn't do anything no their um
religion it was like yeah there was no
way where are they now dude telling me I
could be a hobby land owner today yeah
you can just come in and steal or
whatever no more Quakers they're extinct
that's why they just sell oatmeal they
ain't got they're weak they didn't
transition the brand you know when you
saw that video you weren't offended at
all offended of Japanese dude I the
funny thing is
Japanese number one all day long
yeah
we I mean Japanese people hate the
Imperial Army too man like that's a good
point that's like Germans hate Nazis too
it's like I don't know I don't know I I
think the people that can't disassociate
nationalism and ethnicity are [__]
stupid right like you think it's your
politics is your race like you're dumb
dude yeah so you know how like there's
some uh how there are some Germans that
want to be back in a Nazi back in Nazi
World are there Japanese people that
love Imperial Japan hell yeah like
that's when Japan was there's sometimes
those I mean we got them too right like
the KKK or whatever they they have vans
that like bust like oh propaganda stuff
and then they'll be like we need to go
back to the way things were in Japan
[__] all these Koreans and Chinese get
them out here that's what that's what
it's like yeah with a Southern accent
yeah
oh y'all
yeah like Japan's cool and generally
people just look at those people and
they think they're like knots they're
like shut up you guys are stupid and
they're usually like our version of the
uh
Deliverance yeah the funniest thing is
like all these Master race guys that
come out like when you see them they're
[__] fat and ugly and like or like
they're not people you want to be they
don't look Master racing like they they
don't look fit and good like they're
just like the losers of the society
coming out and then like protesting
because they're just angry right yeah
yeah but they're there and then they
wave the uh the old flag the the Rising
Sun one that's the Karate Kid one yeah
yeah you guys want to hear something
funny during the uh George Floyd uh
riots uh three layer agency again maybe
KFC
um was following this group I think
they're called the good old boys
so they were following this group and
they packed them in the back of this uh
truck and they were Trucking these guys
and they all wore the same thing a polo
shirt khaki pants they all had that's
not the proud boys that's the different
one I think whoever group it was uh my
buddy was working that day and they're
like hey you guys need to stop this
[__] truck
so we they stopped them and they open
the back and they pulled out all because
they were gonna send these guys to go
fight the antifa kids they're gonna be
like a big one yeah so they had them
like sitting on the sidewalk they were
all dressed the same and whatever yeah
they were gonna meet them up and
I guess do a big [__] gang fight I
don't know what you want to think bro
what's that story
how did they know how'd they get the
Intel to know which truck and and that's
a good question man they must have been
following that group for a while
tracking their phones tracking whatever
surveillance they had yeah KFC is real
good yeah go 80t
Brinks Brinks Saves the Day
foreign